we've got some encouraging news for you
this morning the reported number of new
coveted cases in this country fell below
30 000 for the fifth straight day
yesterday and that hasn't happened
since last june that's good one big
reason for that more than 156 million
american adults
have now received at least one
coronavirus vaccine vaccination
president biden's chief medical advisor
you know him dr anthony fauci joins us
he's also the government's top expert on
infectious diseases
good morning to you dr fauci it's really
good to see you as always
thank you gail good to see you okay
here's the thing you're going to be
proud of me
i went outside i'm vaccinated as you
know went outside
walked around without a mask and didn't
feel as guilty as i normally do
isn't that good you're getting there
baby steps making progress and a friend
of mine said gail you just need to relax
you and all the other people who are
vaccinated you are
in a great position you need to start
living your lives what is the confusion
about the mask
why are you worried about it the bottom
line is you don't have to wear a mask
inside you don't have to wear a mask
outside if you're vaccinated and the
people that aren't vaccinated should
still be wearing their mask
is it as simple as that it doesn't seem
so
it really is gail i mean i think that
the the confusion
that people had is that when the cdc
made the announcement that people who
are vaccinated
can really feel safe because of the
extraordinary degree of effectiveness of
the vaccines
whether you're outdoors or indoors
somehow that got interpreted as saying
well
masks forget mass we don't need to wear
masks
which is not the case because the
recommendations for people who are not
vaccinated have not changed they really
remain the same
particularly the issue of wearing masks
when indoors
i think people get confused because you
go to a store and they're saying wear
your mask
and people are walking around saying i'm
i'm not i'm vaccinated so i don't need
to wear a mask
shouldn't we just follow if you're going
to a store and the guidelines and their
their rule is wear a mask
leave your mask on right absolutely
absolutely and the reason why that's the
case is since we don't
have any official way to validate or
verify
that you're vaccinated if you're the
owner of an establishment
you don't have any idea who's vaccinated
who's not there maybe of an infected
people
in the establishment that might infect
other people who are not vaccinated
so in order to just cover the waterfront
they say if you're going to come into my
establishment
wear a mask under those circumstances
even though you are vaccinated
you should abide by what the person says
who owns that establishment
i certainly did that all right so we
cleared that up that's not so confusing
to me but i am worried about the honor
system i may trust me and the people at
this table but it's all
people out there i'm not so sure about
them so i'm very very worried about that
but let's talk about the booster shots
for just a second because we keep
hearing that we're going to need a
booster
uh in the fall about six months that it
only covers you for six months
is that still still tracking that way
you know not necessarily gail again
unfortunately there's
some misunderstanding about that we are
planning for the eventuality that we
might need to boost people
we don't know whether we will have to do
it and when we will have to do it
there's estimates well it may be a year
it may be a little bit longer
the fact is we don't know but it would
really be foolish not to plan for the
possibility
that we might have to boost people but
there's no
set rule now that says in six months or
in a year we're going to get
we're going to require a boost what we
do is we
follow the durability of the response we
know we could measure it by laboratory
tests
but you could also see if there are
breakthrough infections
so rather than people assuming that six
months from now everyone will need a
boost which is not the case
at all we just keep following the
durability of the response
and if the time comes when we'll need to
boost people
will at least have enough data because
we're doing the studies now
to know what we expect to see when we do
boost people
and that's why this is such a moving
target because you're still following
the data trying to gather all the
information it's not that
you guys don't know what you're doing
you're just trying to follow the science
and
trying to figure this out as we go along
okay basketball playoffs opening up all
around the country
what's your guidance for people who are
going to basketball playoffs vaccinated
or non-bat
vaccinated or non-vaccinated because
there are a lot going on this weekend
inside well you know you know gail it's
going to depend on
what the regulations are of the people
who are running the establishment where
the game is being held if they say you
have to have a mask
when you go in then you should be
wearing a mask if they say you don't
need to wear a mask and you are
vaccinated
you really don't need to wear a mask
okay
but people don't always tell the truth
ruth as you know thank you dr anthony
fauci always good to see you i know
we'll talk again
thanks again gayle good to see you bye